>> Well hello everybody on YouTube. This is
Philip Rosedale and I'm the founder of Linden
Lab. We're the company that makes Second Life
and to answer the Davos Question here what
do I think we can do I guess as both people,
I'll answer for both, as individuals and companies
and countries in 2008 to make the world better.
One of the things we've seen happening in
Second Life that is very moving and powerful,
and is something we try to do and live by
as a company, I think in part because we've
seen it happen in the virtual world with Second
Life is a willingness to be transparent. That
is, the world in which we can know more about
what's happening is a better world regardless
of what's happening. I think that if we, and
I think virtual worlds are a first example
of this, if we can be in a place where it's
simply true that it's easier to see what's
going on, it's easier to know what everybody's
doing and you know what their actions are
moment by moment. Not what they want you to
know but in fact what is actually happening.
That is something that I think has the power
to make the world a better place no matter
what. And it always works, and it's very simple,
and it doesn't take governance, and it doesn't
take policy. So I think that's something that
definitely governments, but also companies
and people can and should think about. Just
being open, being transparent, being willing
to share what you're doing with the rest of
the world. Which I guess is appropriate given
using YouTube to answer a question like this
and leave a video. Thank you.